[Musique]
mais c'est que j'ai vu ton de noël tant
et tant de noël noël bretagne par vendre
est furieuse et ken une mère baveuse des
vagues presque noir qui sautait comme
des chevaux passé le petit mur qui
prétend un saint malo protéger la
chaussée du sillon une tempête qui
sentait le printemps trois mois trop tôt
et la pluie tiède désolé prédomine noël
de même en suisse
entre les murs épais d'un hôtel et
déguisements le papier plissé rouge
violet vers les bars de cocteau les
perruques sont paille de bois la crèche
au carton moules et les ponts pillent
les étoiles de crainte qu'on est debout
dans le vol un arbre sévère au résident
un noir sapin immobilise les voeux à
tester la fête dans une ville froide
l'est réveillon auprès d'ingrid charmant
du boudin violet de noir quartier de
s'ennuyer marine et des futurs grands
aplats d'âge
je ne voulais pas certain noël solitaire
ce verger de larmes sous les d'un sony
dans ses draps froissés le jeu
l'europhile contempler la lumière du
jour à celle chagrin récollets jeune
femme noëlle ici noël au loin
et pourquoi pas noël dans mon village
natal c'est comme au village natal ne
s'élèveraient que le premier lion et il
ne faisait guère d'après pour la crèche
la double leboeuf dans l'haleine d'un
chauve depuis 2000 en inde y est une
réelle commémorer noël chez nous sinon
les libres sous son nom populaire rose
de noël elle seule floricel j'avale
décembre et janvier
quand la neige que les bons pendant une
quinzaines j'allège a soulevé par mois
les épées parc route fiable je
n'oubliais de trouver la feuille digit
et lafleur et son bouton en petite
enveloppe flow tâter le petit de
couperose il s'attire épaisse
vous êtes des forêts de l'île de forces
ennemies grisou semaine les coupes et
les sa page qui nous colle est la racine
la vraie jouissance diminué c'est grave
ou plus est bon de temps en temps mais
rappelé que la terre nous appartiennent
avec sa verdir et ses fruits il est
émouvant comme beaucoup d'enfants
citadins ou à venir à eux la fava est
inaccessible porteuse de neige une
étoile et seule fois on m'apportait
lequel skinheads toulon expédié par une
grand-mère maternelle mais oublie enfin
noël et c'est noël souvent flamme bleue
noël là bas noël partout
noël enfin en 1953 noël en face en face
de ma télévision
[Musique]